- Welcome back, everybody.
(audience cheering)
We are here with the
host of "American Idol"
on ABC, Ryan Seacrest, give it up.
(audience cheering)
So, Ryan also co-hosted
"Live with Kelly and Ryan"
for the last few years.
When he decided to leave the show,
Kelly Ripa gave him a very
nice gift, a new golf bag,
(Ryan laughing)
because he wanted to get into golf.
So, it is time to see how good he is
and how much practice
he's gonna have to put in.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- This game is called "Pie Hole in One."
(energetic music)
♪ Pie Hole in One ♪
(energetic music continues)
(audience cheering)
Here to host, please welcome
good friend of the show,
and host of "American
Ninja Warrior" on NBC,
Matt Iseman, everybody.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- What's up, how are you?
- Good, good, good.
- My man.
- [Ryan] How are you, buddy?
- What a pleasure.
- All right.
- Okay.
- About the game.
- It's like looking in the mirror.
- Oh, my God.
- No, that's not the game, we-
- What is going on?
What are you doing?
- So fit.
- Yeah, it's like, I see me and you.
- Yeah.
- So, you're competitive?
- A little bit, you know this.
- Okay, I just started,
I just got the bag.
It's all new to me.
- Whatever,
I don't even play golf.
I'm still gonna beat you somehow.
- By the way,
- [Ryan] (indistinct)
- I'm sitting here with
two incredible hosts.
I'm feeling a little superfluous here,
but I'm so excited for this game.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm a little disappointed to find out
it doesn't involve pie,
but it does involve golf.
So, Kelly,
- Okay.
- you and Ryan each have your own colors
of practice golf balls in front of you.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Now, the point of this
game is to hit those balls
at the board with your faces on it
and get the balls to stick to
areas with the most points.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Ryan] Okay.
- Now, I will be the judge
of how many points your shot gets.
And as the audience
knows, I am always fair
and I never make up rules on the spot.
(audience applauding)
So.
- All right.
- Okay, okay.
- Now, men in the audience,
Ryan, will be playing for you.
(men in the audience cheering)
Ladies, you've got Kelly playing for you.
Now, Kelly, I believe
you played this before.
(ladies in the audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I just remembered.
- [Matt] So, we're-
- I apologize to the men,
and you have an advantage.
You've done this before.
- No, no, no, I just remembered I did this
with Nick Jonas and I was not good.
- All right.
- So, okay, let-
- [Matt] Kelly, you get the first shot.
- Oh, I'm doing the first shot.
- Oh, okay.
Okay, ladies-
- So, you're gonna show
Ryan how it's done.
- [Ryan] Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh, totally.
- I will watch.
- Watch, watch this.
- All right, coach.
- Okay, okay, okay, here we go.
- Backing up.
(ding sound effect)
- Wow.
(audience cheering)
- [Ryan] Come on.
- I don't think I did that before.
- All morning long,
you've been practicing.
- [Kelly] No, I don't think I did that.
- One point shot, Ryan's turn.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Audience] Whoa.
(Kelly laughing)
- Was that too much?
(buzzer sound effect)
- I believe we would say "Seacrest, out."
That ball was not in.
- [Kelly] Seacrest out.
- Seacrest out of bounds.
- [Matt] No points for that, Kelly.
- Oh, my God.
- Like I said,
it's a new golf bag, it's a new hobby.
- I feel like, I feel like,
I don't know guys, okay, here we go.
- I have a heavy club.
- Oh.
- There we go!
- Right on your head.
(audience cheering)
- Ryan's hair, which it isn't marked,
but I'm gonna say, look at his hair,
it's glorious.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- [Kelly] glorious.
- That's a four point shot for Kelly.
(ding sound effect)
- Four, could get a lot.
(audience cheering)
- Seven, nothing.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience oohs)
- Oh, my God.
- What's happening?
- It's.
- [Ryan] All right, wait, now.
I'm hitting behind it.
- This is the greatest.
I've never felt so good about myself.
- Kelly you're up seven, nothing.
- Okay.
- I'm like the Rudy of this game.
- I'm gonna come back.
- Okay, okay, and we're all
gonna clap for you, it's like.
- Yeah, right?
You need somebody to root for.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
(audience cheering)
- What?!
- What are you doing?
- I don't know.
- Ten points!
(ding sound effect)
- I'm telling you, this was
not how I played with Nick.
(ding sound effect)
(audience cheering)
- Oh, my!
- Five!
(air horn sound effect)
- [Kelly] Five.
- [Matt] What a match.
- I shoulda warmed up.
- How's, okay, okay.
- So, Kelly, oh.
- Oh!
- [Kelly] I don't know if that counts.
- I'm sorry, that landed
on zero points for Kelly.
That is not a point.
- I don't if that counts.
- The final shot.
(cymbals crash)
- Oh, my!
- Ooh, it's kind of in between.
- That's on the chin!
- Okay, that's pretty good.
- And that is a five point shot,
(ding sound effect)
- What?!
- in the mouth region.
Which means it's a tie game.
- It's.
- It's a tie game?
- Kelly, you have one shot to win it all.
- Oh, no.
- Oh.
(audience cheering)
- Okay.
- One shot, everything on the line!
- Okay, okay.
- [Audience] Kelly, Kelly!
- Okay, okay, okay.
(audience continues chanting and cheering)
(cymbals crash)
(ding sound effect)
- [Ryan] Oh!
(audience cheering)
You're so good at cheering.
(air horn sound effect)
- So, she wins by one?
- She won.
- Like you really crushed me somehow.
I don't know.
(Kelly laughing)
- I will say, Ryan Seacrest
amongst reality hosts,
you are Tiger Woods,
when it comes to golf,
you are Ryan Seacrest.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Ryan] (indistinct) It's gonna be good.
- Well, of course, everyone's
a winner today, Ryan.
Dave and Buster's is the only place
to eat, drink, play,
and watch in one place,
with hundreds of arcade
games, 40 foot TVs,
ridiculously good food and drinks.
And you'll know firsthand,
because everyone here is
getting a $300 gift card
to Dave and Buster's.
(audience cheering)
Good game, now, everybody
be sure to watch Matt
on "American Ninja Warrior" on NBC.
We have an amazing (indistinct)
with Ryan Seacrest Studios
Program coming up next.
Ryan's gonna go hide
something, surprise her.
You won't wanna miss it,
y'all, stay right here.